MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So we'll continue the
discussion on QED.
In the last video, we
looked at wave equations
and we discussed
Dirac equations.
Now we want to look at solutions
to the Dirac equations.
All right, so remember
that the overall goal now
is to find a description of
spin-half particles, which
we can then use in our
matrix element calculation
in order to get to
cross sections or decay
rates of particles.
If you just ad hoc or
natural choice for a solution
would be a wave
equation, which is
a product of a spinor, which
depends on energy and momentum,
and an exponent.
So we have a free plane wave as
a solution to our free particle
base waveform.
We have to show or
we have to make sure
that this wave equation
satisfies the Dirac equation
as shown here.
Since the spinor depends only
on energy and momentum here,
it's rather simple to
write down the derivatives,
because they only
depend on the exponent.
So we can do this here.
And we find those solutions
here for the four components.
We can rewrite this by putting
those derivatives here back
into the Dirac equation.
What we find then here's this
simplified form for the spinor.
Note that this does not
depend on derivatives anymore.
So this is a rather simple form.
And then we can study--
what happens now if they
have a particle at rest.
So it further simplifies
the Dirac equation.
It further simplifies
here to items E
times gamma 0, u-- that's
our spinor-- equal m times u.
Since gamma 0 is a
diagonal, or is diagonal,
we can immediately find the
eigenstates to this equation.
So we find four
different eigenstates,
and they are orthogonal.
And you find that they
look very similar.
So n here is just the
normalization factor,
which is the same for all four.
And we find those four
different values here.
You can find two with a negative
sign in the exponent and two
with a positive sign
in the exponent.
Now this is for
particles at rest, fine.
We can interpret those solutions
as positive and negative energy
states of a spin-half particles
or a particle with two spin
states.
But now we want to
see what happens
if you have a particle
which is not addressed.
So the way to approach
this is, so once, we
can just apply
Lorentz transformation
and see how the
solutions transform.
But it is even easier
to just look directly
at the Dirac equations
for the spinor.
So we start again from
our equation here.
We just write this down.
And then we rewrite the
equation using the gamma
matrices until we find those
factors p times gamma 1--
px times gamma 1, py
gamma 2, p3 gamma 3.
Can we write this using the
Pauli matrices in this form?
OK, so what this gives us is
this coupled form of equations.
So here we revised our spinor
as a two vector, uA and uB.
And you find the coupled
form between those two
if we look at those
set of equations.
Great.
But this is rather
cumbersome and complicated.
However, now we can try
to find the solutions
or try to find eigenstates
to the equation.
We know that the solutions
are of this form here.
That's how we started.
If you then try to find
a specific [? state, ?]
you can start from the
simplest alternate solution,
which is uA equal 1, 0.
And then just put this in here.
And you find for u1
those solutions here.
And then you turn this around.
For uB, you find 1 and 0 and
you find the other solution.
So similarly as for
the solutions at rest,
we find here for our
spinors that there
is four different spinors,
which are independent.
You can interpret
them now as, again,
the positive and
negative energy states.
So if you then,
for example, say,
OK, let's make sure that
this is all consistent,
we want to see that
when the momentum is 0,
you come back to the
previous solution.
If you look at the
momentum, if they're 0,
those components are all here--
become 0, you find
the very same solution
as we had on the previous page.
You can also ask
yourself what happens now
if you don't use this idea of
positive and negative energy
solutions.
If you want to do
that and you define
that as all are either
positive for energy solutions,
and not two positive
and two negative,
you find that you
can divide them
as linear combinations
of the others,
so they're not
independent solutions.
So in order to have four
independent solution
of the Dirac equations,
two have to be positive
and two have to be
negative in energy.
All right, so I
recommend just trying
the exercise of playing
around with the Pauli matrices
and the gamma matrices.
If you have not
seen this before,
it's not easy to
follow the algebra.
But once you get
a hang of it, it's
actually not that complicated.
In the next lecture, we look
at the solutions-- specifically
the solutions for
antiparticles a little bit more
and discuss interpretations
of those solutions.